Jetzt.
Okay.
Guten Tag.
Ich bin auf die Station aus Asst.
Ich würde mit Ihnen das auch noch mal gesprochen.
Darf Ihnen Namen erfahren?
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Jessica.
Jessica.
Vorname Jessica.
Mit C.
Soll ich den Namen Buch stabilen?
Bitte.
Ich bin jetzt nicht der Buch stabilen.
Ja.
Je.
S.
Jessica.
C.
A.
Und der Name?
Der Nachname ist Karma.
K.
R.
A.
Karma.
Ja.
Frau Karma, wie alt sind Sie?
27 Jahre.
Wie spät sind Sie?
60 Kilo.
60 Kilo?
Wie groß sind Sie?
1 Meter 74.
44.
Ja.
Was haben Sie überschwellen? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, ich habe so vor einer Stunde begann das ganz plötzlich, da kriegte ich ganz plötzlich Luftnot.
Ich kriegte keine Luft mehr und hatte einen starken Schmerz in der linken Brust, ja auf der linken Seite.
Ja, aber hauptsächlich starke Luftnot. Das begann ganz plötzlich.
Öhm, fühlen Sie sich andere Beschwerde?
Nein, keine wesentlichen anderen Beschwerden gehabt, das war ganz plötzlich, fing vor einer Stunde an.
Vorher haben Sie eine chronische Erkrankung von Ihnen bekannt?
Eine Bräunchenerkrankung? Oder chronische Erkrankung?
Ich nehme ein Mittel für die Schildrüse ein, wegen einer Schildrüsenunterfunktion, aber ich habe sonst keine chronische Erkrankung.
Ist der Schmerz dauerhaft?
Ja, der ist ganz stark, der ist dauerhaft.
Wie sagt man sich Schmerz, so wie ich habe, eine Skala, wobei nun leichter Schmerz und sehr starker und verträglicher Schmerz.
Wie können Sie dieses Schmerz in Stärke 8?
Stärke 8. Haben Sie Husten?
Wie bitte?
Haben Sie Husten?
Nein, ich kriege gar keine Luft, ich kann gar nicht richtig atmen, nee, Husten habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie diese Beschwerden miteinander begonnen?
Die habe ich noch nie gehabt zu beschwerden.
Die habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Es ist ganz plötzlich gekommen, vor einer Stunde kam das.
Mit einander begonnen, oder?
Wie haben die Schmerzen begonnen?
Diese Beschwerden.
Ja.
Ist es miteinander begonnen?
Hintereinander.
Ja.
Haben diese Beschwerden miteinander begonnen?
Ich verstehe, ich habe das nicht verstanden, was Sie meinen.
Verstärkst du diese Schmerzen, diese Luftnot?
Ja.
Was wird das sein?
Das fing gleich vor einer Stunde an, sofort, ganz starker Schmerz und jetzt habe ich ganz starke Luftnot.
Ich kriege kaum Luft, ich kann ganz schlecht mich hinsetzen.
Haben Sie viele?
Nein, viele habe ich nicht.
Aber Herr Srasen?
Ja, ich glaube schon, dass das Herz ziemlich schnell schlägt.
Öh, fühlen Sie sich ab Geschleppernheit?
Ab Geschleppernheit.
Auf Schwöhe.
Ja.
Leiden unter Schwarzaufbrücke?
Ja, jetzt seit dieser Stunde bin ich, habe ich ganz schön geschwitzt plötzlich.
Aber das ist erst jetzt seit einer Stunde.
Zum Beispiel, leiden Sie unter abgeschwollene Beine oder
andere Begleitende Beschwerden oder wichtigsten Krankheiten und Ihnen wissen.
Abgeschwollenes Bein habe ich seit einer Woche, da bin ich beim Joggen umgeknickt mit dem Fuß
und seitdem ist mein Schnöchel ganz dick und der unterschenkelt.
Das ist seit einer Woche und da habe ich einfach eine Bandage drum gemacht,
eine elastische Binde und meine Schwester sagt zu mir, ich muss damit zum Arzt gehen.
Das muss angeschaut, geröntcht werden, ob da vielleicht was gebrochen ist am Fuß
oder berissen ist. Aber ja, der ist halt ganz schön dick jetzt seit einer Woche.
Nehmen Sie da wir gehen eine Wohlverdünne ein?
Nein.
Ich war bisher deswegen auch noch nicht beim Arzt.
Wahrscheinlich das wäre eine direkte, direkte Situation.
Sie müssen.
Hab ich nicht verstanden, können Sie es mir noch?
Diese Beschwerden ist eine direkte Situation.
Das ist wahrscheinlich eine ungen Emolie.
Was mache ich jetzt?
Sie sind sofort aufgenommen in der Station.
Ja, eine Lungenembolie.
Das kann mit dem Fuß tun haben.
Das müssen wir Ihnen eine Sauerstoff und in den Wernen eine Verdünne mitteilen.
Das kann das mit dem Fuß zu tun haben.
Die Ursache kann in dem Fuß liegen, in der Schwellung, im Bein, im Unterschenkel.
Ja.
Die gebrochene Flussenten und staubende Beine.
Es kann sein auch diesem Grund.
Ja, okay.
Wenn Sie mir helfen können, wäre das gut.
Ich habe auch so starke Schmerzen beim Atmen.
Ich habe Ihnen einige Schmerzlindern, Medikamente, Sauerstoff und verschiedene wichtigste Verdünne.
Das machen Sie jetzt sofort.
Sie müssen eine Maschine überwachen.
Ja, auf alle Fälle.
Das klingt ja sehr gefährlich, eine Lungenembolie.
Nehmen Sie eine Pille?
Ja, ich nehme die Pille.
Ist es möglich, dass Sie sich schon gesügt?
Nein, nein.
Da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, nein.
Reagieren Sie zum Beispiel, bestimmte Lebensmittel oder einige Herzleimittel?
Das waren gerade andere Geräusche.
Ich habe das jetzt letzte nicht verstanden.
Ich hatte gerade andere Geräusche hier gehört.
Haben Sie allergie?
Ich habe keine allergie.
Ich nehme nur zwei Medikamente, einmal für die Schilddrüse und einmal die Pille.
Ich fühle mich sonst auch immer ganz gesund.
Ich mache viel Sport und ich ernähre mich gesund.
Aber das war jetzt etwas ganz Blödsliches, ganz Schlimmes.
Papis in Ihrer Familie, die Erbaren oder die Krönchen erkrankt.
In der Familie?
Ja.
Meine Eltern, die leben beide noch.
Der Vater ist 57 Jahre alt und hat Asthma.
Aber damit kommt er gut zurecht.
Er ist gut behandelt.
Die Mutter ist 56 Jahre alt und hat Gelenkrömer.
Aber die fühlt sich eigentlich auch ganz gut.
Es ist auch gut eingestellt von den Medikamenten her.
Und dann habe ich noch einen Bruder, 24 Jahre, der ist gesund.
Und einen Bruder, der ist gut behandelt.
Und dann habe ich noch einen Bruder, der ist gut behandelt.
Und dann habe ich noch einen Bruder, 24 Jahre, der ist gesund.
Und eine Schreste, 29 Jahre alt.
Die hat auch Schilddrüssen unter Funktion, so wie ich.
Ihre Mutter, die Freundin leiden.
Die Mutter?
Ja.
Die Mutter hat eigentlich nur Gelenkrömer.
Mehr weiß ich nicht, was die Mutter hat.
Was ist das?
Wie bitte?
Sie hat ein tolles Reulingerlenke und nimmt auch Spezialmedikamente ein.
Aber damit ist sie gut.
Sie haben gut angesprochen, die Medikamente.
Sie fühlt sich jetzt wieder besser.
Sind ihr Impfungen ausständig?
Die Impfungen?
Ja, ich habe alle Impfungen.
Ich bin jetzt auch schon zum dritten Mal geimpft.
Corona-Impfungen?
Ich habe einen Booster bekommen.
Ist alles gut.
Arbeiten Sie?
Ja, ich bin Architektin.
Sind Sie verharartet?
Nein, bin nicht verharartet.
Aber sind Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Haben Sie etwas fragen?
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Mich interessiert jetzt, was jetzt mit mir passiert.
Was machen Sie?
Ich habe noch etwas zu tun.
Was macht Ihr mit mir?
Sie tut mit mir aus.
Es hat soy Shirth und es noch meine Medikamente,
Masl Hammed,
eine Episode 14,
eine Torax-Unfassung darstellen.
Okay.
Gut.
Ja.
Und auch routinämäßig verschiedene Brutung untersuchen
und Brutwerte veranlassen.
Wichtig ist jetzt, dass ich wieder besser Luft bekomme.
Dass meine Luft wieder besser ist.
Ich habe so wenig Luft.
Sie haben ein bisschen geduld mit diesen Massnahmen.
Sie werden einige Stunden hoffentlich heilen.
Okay.
Ja.
Hallo.
Ja, ich verstehe nichts.
Ja.
Gut.
Dann haben wir jetzt erstmal Anamnese beendet
und sie schreiben sich etwas auf und...
Ja, ich bin viel, viel praktisch mit dem Anamnese.
Ja.
Okay.
5 Minuten?
Ja.
Okay.
Bis gleich.
Ja.
Danke.
Herr Schöp, guten Tag.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Okay.
Ja.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patientin in der Nacht.
Okay.
Ja.
60 kg, schwer und ein Mitte 74 kg.
Allgemein, die Zustand ist schlecht.
Ihr Kreislaufstation ist nie stabil.
Sie hat eine Taktik und eine Ernehmlich- und Sauerstoff-Sätikung.
Sie kann uns vor einer Stunde starker schmassen,
mit schweren Dispner.
Wo sind die Schmerzen?
Schmerzen liegt bei 8 und 10.
Wo sind die Schmerzen lokalisiert?
Schmerzen liegt auf welcher Seite?
Auf welcher Seite?
Disple und starke Voluschimercen.
Okay, gibt es eine?
In der Vorgeschichte der Patienten hat eine vor einige Woche Schupunkelenk umgeknickt.
Eine Sprunggelenks-Distortion.
Distortion.
Distortion, ja.
Vor einigen Wochen oder vor einer Woche?
Vor einer Woche.
Nach diesem Erreignis habe ich leider irgendwelche Prognosen oder Heparin nicht angenommen.
Wahrscheinlich auch diesem Begründen kommt es so eine Lungenembolie.
Das ist jetzt Ihre Verdachtdiagnose, Lumenembolie?
Ja, Lungenembolie.
Die Patientin war vorher nicht beim Arzt nach diesem Unfall.
Die Distortion hat sich selbst behandelt?
Oder war sie bei einem Arzt zur Untersuchung?
Ich habe das nicht gefragt.
Die Patientin hat es gesagt, sie hat das selbst behandelt.
Also ohne Arzt.
Okay, ja, Lungenembolie, das ist natürlich eine schwere, lebensbedrohliche Erkrankung.
Was könnte effinzialdiagnostisch sein?
Was kommt effinzialdiagnostisch in Betracht bei dieser Symptomatik?
Ja, eine Corona-Syndrom.
Zum Beispiel eine Pyramotorax.
Eine neue Motoraxe?
Wahrscheinlich.
Aber auch die Sektion in Betracht.
Möglich ist es.
Aber auf der anderen Seite bei der Vorgeschichte, Distortion, Sprunggelenk vor einer Woche.
Wie Sie berichten, muss man her an eine Lungenembolie denken.
Plötzliches Ereignis, nimmt die Patientin die Pille?
In der Anämnese der Patient berichtet,
regelmäßig eine Pille.
Gut, das wäre jetzt noch ein zusätzlicher Risikofaktor.
Zusätzlicher Risikofaktor.
Seit einer Woche, die rechte Beine,
ist der wirkliche Rot und strahlende Blut.
Das ist eine Risikofilmung.
Hat die Patientin sonst noch chronische Erkrankungen oder eine auffällige Vorgeschichte?
Sie leitet es an die Portugäude.
Und regelmäßig nehmen Sie eine Theoid-Refrasern ein.
Wahrscheinlich Hashimoto, Thürioiditis, vielleicht Portugose.
Hat die Patientin sonst Risikofaktoren, raucht sie?
Ich glaube, sie hat nicht gefragt.
Man hat zumindest noch mal diese Risikofaktoren abgefragt.
Ob sie raucht, wie es mit Alkohol ist, Drogenkonsum.
Was unternehmen Sie jetzt, Herr Kollege, an Therapie?
Wenn Sie meinen Verdacht der Erkrankungen bestätigen,
entfällig eine bei dieser Patientin verwendete Therapie-Massnahmen erfolgen.
Erstmal eine Zauberstoff mit Nasen und eine Traumolitische Therapie.
Erstmal eine intravenöse Patientin,
dann müssen wir sofort eine Traumolitische Therapie beginnen.
Dann eine nachfolgende Bildgebung.
Man kann Computer-Tomographie machen.
Dann ist das erstmal in Ordnung.
Mit dem Therapievorschlag, die Diagnose würde ich auch unterstützen.
Wie das geschildert wird und wie das, denke ich, die Befunde da sind,
muss man daran denken.
Das Trauma, Distortion der Sprunggelenke, das passt ja.
Sonst ist die Frau ja offenkundig gesund.
Risikofaktor die Pille, aber das ist jetzt ein begleitender Risikofaktor.
Jetzt machen wir vielleicht Schluss.
Ich sage noch mal, woran Sie denken sollten, bei der Aufnahme.
Sie haben das zwar angedeutet, aber sagen, wenn jemand so stark kommt,
mit einer starken Dispnö, Luftnot und Schmerzen,
während man befragt, schildern und sagen,
während der Zeit, wo ich sie befrage,
messe ich Ihren Blutdruck, messe ich Ihren Sauerstoffgehalt in Blut.
Blutdruckmessen, SBO2-Messen.
Um zu schauen, ist die Patientin kreislaufstabil.
Was macht Ihre Sauerstoffversorgung als Orientierung?
Das beruhigt die Patientin auch.
Es wird nicht nur gefragt, sondern schon etwas gemacht.
Das ist ein wichtiger Faktor.
Damit kann man auch ganz gut bestimmte Dinge beruhigen.
Die Patientin hat ja eine Panik.
Sie hat ja schlecht Luft, sie kriegt keine richtige Luft.
Die eine Lunge ist eine schwere Lungenembolie.
Sie ist ausgefallen und hat Schmerzen.
Sie ist jetzt natürlich sehr ängstlich.
Was ist jetzt passiert?
Diese Situation sollte man eine Analyse an der Juditik verbrechen.
Ja, kann man durchaus machen, einen Zugang legen,
einen wenigsten Zugang legen schon mal.
Als Sicherheit sagen, ich lege Ihnen jetzt einen Zugang,
ich untersuche Ihr Sauerstoffgehalt in Blut,
messe Ihren Blutdruck.
Das ist ja vielleicht parallel ein Not-EKG.
Im Ambulanz schon umzuschauen,
hat sie gegebenenfalls auch noch schwere Herz-Rot-Mostörungen.
Oder ist es nur eine Tachikadie?
Ja, so.
Und dann kann man die Analyse ja, je nach Notsituation,
entweder macht man die Analyse dann erst mal gar nicht weiter,
sondern erst mal eine Intervention.
Aber das haben Sie ja schon richtig gesagt.
Sie waren ja schon sehr schnell bei der Diagnose der Lungenembuli.
Ich habe Ihnen etwas geholfen,
als Sie gesagt haben, haben Sie geschwollene Beine.
Und dann habe ich geantwortet normalerweise nicht.
Aber seit einer Woche ist mein Sprunggeling geschwollen,
nachdem ich umgeknickt bin.
Und da haben Sie sofort, denke ich, richtig kombiniert und gesagt,
das kann eine Lungenembuli sein.
Man muss der Patientin vielleicht die Diagnose gar nicht sagen.
Sondern erst mal für sich diese Alarmdiagnose haben
und dann verfolgen.
Wenn man der Patientin vielleicht sagt, Sie haben eine Lungenembuli,
dann kann sie schon noch mehr in Panik kommen und denken,
oh, da ist mein Nachbar dran verstorben,
eine Lungenembuli, das kann ja sein,
es ist ja eine lebensbedrohliche Erkrankung.
Vielleicht mit der Diagnose gegenüber der Patientin noch abwarten.
Aber ansonsten, denke ich, haben Sie das gut systematisiert
und auch vorgeschlagen, was Sie jetzt machen wollen.
Bei so Notfällen ist es immer etwas anders
als bei einer normalen Anamnese, wo man Zeit hat,
wo man in aller Ruhe sagen kann.
Aber wenn jemand so ermittelt,
was kommt wie Verdacht auf Lungenembuli
oder Verdacht auf Herzinfarkt oder Verdacht auf Herzinfarkt,
dann muss man erstmal ein paar Handlungen machen
zur diagnostischen Sinne, um zu sagen,
der Patient ist kreislaufstabil, das ist in Ordnung.
Oder wenn der Blutdruck sehr niedrig ist,
dann muss ich natürlich schon andere Maßnahmen ergreifen.
Das ist klar.
Gut.
Ja, versuchen Sie beim Sprechen auch möglichst immer
den Interviewer anzuschauen und nicht nach unten zu sprechen
auf Ihr Blatt Papier, das machen Sie manchmal.
Und dann kann ich Sie schlechter verstehen.
Wenn Sie direkt mich ansprechen, geht das etwas leichter,
als wenn Sie so fragen, verstehen Sie?
Haben Sie nicht immer gemacht, aber manchmal.
Nur daran denken für die Prüfung, so als Verhalten.
Das ist dann manchmal leichter.
Wesser ist den Blickkontakt,
und dann können manche Menschen auch besser ihre Lippen sehen
und das auch verstehen.
Als wenn Sie so nach unten fragen.
Ja, gut.
Ja, gibt es sonst noch Fragen
oder sollen wir noch irgendwas klären zu dem Thema
oder nicht oder Vorschläge?
Vorschläge bei der Patientin
und andere wichtigste klinischen wesentlichen Informationen.
Achten Sie noch bitte einmal drauf.
Sie gegenüber beim Oberarzt natürlich.
Das haben Sie aber auch wirklich gut gemacht.
Medizinische Ausdrücke verwenden.
Für Luft, Not, Dispnoe, Herz, Rasen.
Ja, könnte ich sagen, mein wegen der Puls ist Tachrikat.
Oder dann kurz berichten,
SPO 2 oder eben versuchen,
einige medizinische Begriffe
bei der Oberarztvorstellung zu einzubringen.
Nicht anders als in der Anamnese bei der Patientin.
Aber das haben Sie weitgehend gut gemacht.
Gut.
Ja, wenn wir sonst nichts mehr besprechen sollen,
dann können wir das auch beenden.
Wo haben Sie die Prüfung?